Addison Ray's mom Sherry easterling and
a rapper Young gravy call it quits with
news coming after the former couple made
their red carpet debut at the VMAs in
August but that doesn't mean Sherry is
back in Addison's good graces a source
sells E.T that Addison is still quote
upset about everything what is the
obsession with no is there more
experienced they are an underserviced
Community I'd like to say and when it
comes to the breakup an Insider says
Sherry and gravy have gone back and
forth a lot quote that relationship was
chaotic and hectic they initially got
together for fun for attention and to
cause headlines it was never meant to be
a real or serious thing the romance
between 26 year old gravy and 42 year
old Sherry caused a lot of tension
between her family who were already
dealing with drama after her ex-husband
Monty Lopez was accused of infidelity in
July Lopez even went on to challenge
gravy to a boxing match in August
something that at the time A source told
ET had Addison quote embarrassed
and now that Sherry and young gravy are
done she's still experiencing backlash
quote it's not fair to the kids Addison
is keeping minimal contact with her mom
but they are talking a little more now
since the breakup with our Insider
adding quote people who used to be
friends with Addison's parents as a
couple don't talk to them anymore
[Applause]
enduring their red carpet debut Sherry
revealed what was special about gravy
what is it about young gravy
he's very wholesome I would say
believe it or not I am a wholesome
person I am wholesome you know what I
felt like the response that you gave to
Addison's father on Tick Tock after he
challenged you to a fight was pretty
mature I thought it was an appropriate I
feel like I am a lot more you know I
feel like that as a 26 year old I'm a
lot more mature than you know that type
of activity so what did you make of The
Tick Tock activity
um I don't I don't know let's not worry
about it
foreign